[Music]
as soon as i found react it became clear
that this was the right way to do things
what i love about react is that it's
going to set your career up for years to
come
as a front-end developer things are
constantly changing
the patterns you'll see in react are the
same patterns current and future
front-end frameworks will utilize
not to mention learning react will
enable you to build web apps native apps
or even apps in virtual reality
by learning react today you are
future-proofing your career
hi i'm tyler mcguinness i'm from eden
utah i'm a google developer expert and i
work full-time on tylermegness.com
the paradigms and the principles that
you learn in react are all of a sudden
becoming popular in all these other
frameworks so by learning react react
isn't just going to teach you a new api
it's going to help you learn nice
software principles that you can then
apply to different frameworks and
languages
what i really like about this
collaboration is that it combines both
of our strengths i've been teaching
react in the react ecosystem for a few
years now so i feel like i have a pretty
good grasp on how to teach it and what
udacity provides that i can't are things
like code reviews mentorships and the
in-class experience
we think it's going to make you a much
better developer so come join us
you